bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france on est encore loin de la
réconciliation entre le pouvoir
vénézuélien et l'opposition est ce qu'on
peut vraiment s'attendre à un
rapprochement entre les deux camps et
comment pourrait-il selon se traduire
bonjour merci pour l'invitation alors le
les processus de dialogue qui a lieu en
ce moment donc au mexique concerne un
des secteurs de l'opposition non
l'opposition est plurielle l'opposition
charlie semé plurielle et il y a déjà
toute une partie de ce secteur politique
de cette frange politique qui a déjà qui
participent aux élections qui
participent à la vie politique du pays
donc là nous avons affaire au secteur le
plus radical n'est ce pas celui qui
avait soutenu la tentative de coup
d'état institutionnel
représentée par monsieur boyer dos il ne
n'a échappé à personne que le pouvoir
aux états unis a changé et que les les
états unis les les puissances qui avait
soutenu cette tentative de coup d'état
institutionnel sont décidés à tourner la
page
de fait nous le voyons non seulement
avec la tenue de ce dialogue le secteur
de l'opposition de ne te donnerai à
bouger un doigt sans évidemment
l'autorisation des états unis et puis
nous voyons d'autres pays qui sont en
train de sortir de cet imbroglio
institutionnel par le 11 ans
particulièrement l'espagne qui dit hier
a reconnu de faire de facto le
constitutionnel du président magro en
demandant à ses ambassadeurs d'inviter
les les représentants de la république
bolivarienne du venezuela sa fête
nationale
donc nous sommes effectivement dans un
processus de dialogue qui avec un
secteur de l'opposition qui avance petit
à petit comme vous l'avait dit et qui en
interne c'est d'ailleurs au venezuela se
traduit par la participation des partis
aux élections aux prochaines élections
qui n'auront pas lieu en 2024 comme
mentionné dans votre petit reportage
mais le 21 novembre 2000 21 c'est à dire
dans deux mois il y aura les élections
municipales
et régionales qu'est ce qui est en jeu
du côté du pouvoir vénézuélien s'est
notamment la fin des sanctions imposées
par les pays qui ne reconnaissent pas la
réélection de nicolas maduro en 2018
oui évidemment c'est le principal je
pense que le
le but tenants du pouvoir à caracas et
comme l'a toujours été l'amélioration
des conditions de vie de sa population
conditions de vie qui ont évidemment
baissé sous les coups de du blocus
criminel
ouvert en 2014 non ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas neuf mais qui a pris des dimensions
terrible à partir de du mandat de donald
trump évidemment c'est là le premier
point de deux du gouvernement
vénézuélien n'est ce pas je pense que
ces sanctions ne enfin le dialogue
entamé n'aboutira pas à la levée des
sanctions de garder beaucoup d'autres
choses qui changent ou mais à un
aménagement progressif au fil du temps
que ça évidemment c'est la première des
démotivation va dire du pouvoir du
pouvoir vénézuélien juan garrido qui
représente vous le rappeliez une partie
de l'opposition vénézuélienne a été
reconnu comme président par intérim par
une cinquantaine de pays dont les états
unis qu'est ce qu'il pèse aujourd'hui au
venezuela et plus largement sur la scène
internationale selon vous
alors je pense que roanne et why do donc
qui a joué le rôle c'était le la la
façade ce dos légal qui a légitimé le
pillage du venezuela par
plusieurs puissances occidentales
notamment avec le vol des actifs de la
république bolivarienne du venezuela que
ce soit des dépôts en compte dans les
comptes en banques ou des entreprises
comme si beau ou mono mais rossi
pétrochimiques ou pétrolières donc ça
c'était le rôle de gwen tôt aujourd'hui
gouaille dos nu n'est vraiment plus rien
y compris au sein de son propre camp
j'en veux pour preuve les déclarations
des yachts abrams elliott abrams donc et
un ancien criminel de guerre et qui
avait été nommé par le le par donald
trump comme envoyé spécial des
etats-unis pour le venezuela qui avait
coordiner la stratégie des etats-unis
dans le coup d'état institutionnel avec
comme figures monsieur wade au elliott
abrams le 24 septembre c'est-à-dire il
ya quelques jours sur la chaîne de miami
vtv a parlé de why do au passé et a dit
que la figure de la présidence
intérimaire était dépassée que walid au
resterait aujourd'hui un des dirigeants
de l'opposition je vois que même en cela
il reste très optimiste je pense que ce
personnage devrait peu à peu disparaître
de la vie politique vénézuélienne merci
beaucoup d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation romain miguet journaliste
fondateur du site francophone
d'actualité de l'amérique latine les
tories